and I care about either version of this
song you know love this song no I love
this song but I didn't love it the
eighties I didn't listen to it in the
80s
as usual Don I started by Huey Lewis hi
Joel no oh yeah you can't hear any more
right Don Henley oh yeah yeah I just
saying I know Kara but we were listening
the Ataris version of this song earlier
yeah well you know I don't like the
Ataris version right nod not really I
mean it's fine this is better this is
yes it's the original I mean covers are
fine sometimes like all along the
watchtowers Bob Dylan said it was a
better version than his version but this
is pretty classic yeah sometimes it
covers a little bit better but this is
not this doesn't need to be fixed no and
then they also did smooth criminal the
Ataris the Alien Ant I can't keep it all
straight
well I think we can all agree that alien
ant farms version is the superior
version of smooth criminal right I mean
nice talking to guys well I do like
their version I hate to admit it what I
do like their version okay I like fun
it's fast yeah yeah that is one of my
favorite Michael Jackson songs smooth
criminal oh yeah the original how are
you I can't enjoy him highly be that I
like I like I cannot enjoy him just
because he's trying to be cool and I
can't look at you I'm not a cool dude
cool well it it definitely tarnished
towards the end you mean with the kid
stuff last album what are you talking
about I tell you this though after he
died and they put out that documentary
all the bad stuff was forgotten about is
you were sitting in the movie theater
going like yeah he was [ __ ] awesome
and he's kind of crazy how they keep
that stuff yeah in Donald Donald Glover
now I'm in his stand-up he used to say
you know it was worth it it was pretty
good joke you traps like huge dude
you're [ __ ] getting very large thank
you I started all the gin
what do we do is Arizona where it was a
yeah yes we were in the that resort gym
yeah we do this guy did the Bradshaw
roast or something and I saw you in the
urine animal
the gym so you really you've not stopped
going uh I'm in a state of desperation
all the time I'm like I'm 46 so I'm like
just hold on for it until I hope I you
know when I die I hope I'm at least
slightly toned
yeah I understand that I've never really
been toned is that right you pray look
at you you're great look thanks Sam but
you're just saying that could be a
company usually tell gotta pay a lump of
[ __ ] are you do you go to the bar every
day four days a week
do you go often that's a polite question
by the way what a nice guy you are look
at Sam you do you go as well Sam I can't
tell I mean you're Steve Agee clothing
right yeah no he does not know I tell me
when to a barber yes no yeah i go to i
go to the gym or crush yeah that's great
yeah no I go to are very skinny though
yes boss skinny fat
yeah no yeah thing I did I told Jim I
started going to the gym again and I go
like maybe maybe I squeeze in three
times so we might want to say three
times a week do you know much more that
is that most of America you think so oh
it's three times more babies like he
doesn't know three times twice a week
more like so it I can say twice a week
with confidence three times a week is
like a really great but you know you're
not one of those people that gets on the
the elliptical or the bike and reads a
magazine
no no we go one week when we go we go we
sweat because Jim was you were sweating
and and I mean that you were working
hard he was waiting for my test results
I was nervous the nerves Terry Bradshaw
was there he uh by the way did you do
that roast I remember yes that was a
weird one right it was an odd thing they
were not a good comedy audience they
were they were a bunch of real estate
agent you hosted it yes yes okay and it
was it wasn't and you couldn't really
say everything you wanted to say and
then they edited it down to 22 minutes
the the final version that aired on ESPN
was very very short and how many people
were on the dais
eight yeah it was Joel hosted myself
Jeff Ross McEvoy was his name who's the
black guy on the I don't see color
that's great w my
you might have heard that's a good pie I
didn't notice either to some point who's
that guy oh my god he's was more Brad
choice broadcast partners right yes
boy boy it shows you how little I've
gotten yeah and then what's at Lisa
Lampanelli was there Lisa was out yeah
she was very funny 22 minutes that's
crazy I know it was like an hour two
hours and and and the Owen oh how he
long yeah Joe Montana talked Montana was
in the audience
oh no no no I'm so I'm thinking of uh
Joe um oh my god do we suck this is Joe
Namath yes was there he was in the oh he
left like not long into it is that ready
for the whole show I got I got to meet
him on the red carpet I was happy about
that but there wasn't the kind of spirit
of of a roast where people were like
ready to and because Terry he's game for
anything he was he was money I thought
he would be a dick he was much nicer
than I thought he would but he was great
but you see all the time now with all
the celebrity roasts culture that exists
and everything then there's always
either people or audience members or
whoever it is that don't understand
yes psychology I mean it is yeah yeah
and they end up either bombing or just
like not having a good time like I think
there was a story about Ludacris hating
the whole thing because he didn't
underlying made fun of he he's a baby
that we interviewed him once at k-rock
and and he was just like I mean him and
Patrice he was uncomfortable with
Patrice was trying to be cool to his
tell that he was we asked about the
O'Reilly thing didn't like that but just
to see how to hate how did this change
you or what happened he's all you're
going back along and so what he wants to
do 15 minutes of your [ __ ] movie go
ahead give us the whole plot so the
anger is still still fresh it's annoying
because guys come in and they want to
promote their movie great we're happy
promoter but then you ask him questions
and they're like well you got to see the
movie
cool you run the interview right this is
like eight years ago by the way a long
time ago the wound is still open five
swine but it is weirdly Paul Walker he
did hide the roaches yeah at the Rose
people were bringing up Paul Walker's
and I headed out is yeah if they were
edited out remember when when the
situation bombed when he did the roads I
do remember that that's fun to worry the
situation mom to can yeah yeah I know
it's
time talking everybody has a bad night
every now and then you were hosting the
ESPYs - I don't know I don't know if
we've talked about I guess we haven't
when when Caitlyn made was awarded the
Arthur Ashe Courage Award how was it
hosting that and did they tell you to
not make fun of her or was it what did
you I don't even know if you did or not
oh well it was the first joke I made Oh
what uh yeah it was I was like this is
the I am the only I'm of the two e
personalities here I'm the one you do
not care about and but it is like a very
because all the athletes are in the
first like ten rows and they all have
sunglasses on and none of them are there
- laughs so you were there either
worried that they're gonna be made fun
if some were very cool but you could
tell that that did you make fun of
anyone who didn't enjoy it I don't oh I
think I think what when I made fun of
what's-his-name
she this is a little sleep I've gotten
from the quarterback of the deal
quarterback out of Green Bay you know
Favre yes when I called AI was look for
the guy in dad jeans it's Brett Favre it
wasn't that harsh of it but they cut him
he was like huh and he was it didn't
seem happy maybe he was thrilled I don't
know but you have to kind of go beyond
the road so it kind of where and then I
ended on a Bill Cosby joke so it they
laugh they like they love that so when
you look at and do an audience right and
you make something as innocent as like a
dad jeans joke and you realize that the
guy isn't having a good time with it are
you like Oh Mike
no then that makes me happy if you like
that then I know it actually it works
both ways because you're like oh it got
you were you were touched by that right
that bothered you and that as a comic
makes me besides make me happy and when
they're when they go along with the joke
then it's you know and it's like when
Seth Meyers made fun of Trump at the
White House course monster he was
unhappy and for a comic that's a gift
I mean what no matter what your politics
are and you know when you go after
someone and they they get hurt then
that's kind of yeah everybody else is
enjoying it yes when everyone else is
enjoying it was like he made fun of
Brett Favre in his awful dump dick
selfie remember that awful in this twist
you know he's packing six what yeah
you're Brett Favre's dick picture
whereas if they show his dumb Claudia's
jellies in the [ __ ] papers really
thinking about was Brett Favre and the
joke is
about my dad jeans I'd be like oh great
I got off with easy Jen Selter is that
her no there's another girl who's the
girl he sent to that's it yeah he took
that why reporter why would you do it
you're awful oh yeah they've reportedly
maybe he's got big hands really trims he
does he does he's well-groomed what's
her name
allegedly Oh Jen sorry sorry she's a
Jets fan but he said I don't know this
was that but this is a long time ago
this is years ago yeah 2008 she said or
2010 as this show called
just try to remember stuff we really
don't like um anything topical I can't
remember how was Kate did you meet
Caitlyn that night I guess you'd never
met Caitlyn
you did not meet that night no I I had
heard in the when the car dad years ago
when the Kardashians came on when they
came on the soup and this was before
Caitlyn transitioned they're like
they're like doesn't does not like you
at all
yeah it was not yeah there was a guy at
that time was not not a fan someone come
on I'm just gonna oh we didn't I don't
think I think we offered all the
Kardashians to come on and there was
that but it's not gonna happen
come on he did he I mean it's Bruce he
did not come yeah I love that they
didn't like beat around the bush so we
want you to know about Bruce not a fan
of yours not like I liked it how they
were so low he hates you that's the
Kardashian secret rep one is that
they're really nice yeah as opposed to a
lot of react the time reality show stars
that go I am a star I'm a celebrity
I am the read I'm talented and then they
become horrible so arrogant dicks and
they were they their secret weapons that
like their crew likes them and all that
which makes me you know drives me nuts
right does the just doing the soup and
now do the Netflix I like the fact that
you have to just cram so much content
into your brain for a short period of
time so you can do the show and then
move on to the next thing and be aware
of this this this and this do you think
that affects like your memory in terms
of hanging onto stuff I think not
sleeping well for two days affects me
worse but thank god there's a staff of
young people that can go
old man here yes Braxton Family Values
okay great I'll make fun of that
so ya begin between the the writers are
incredibly helpful so ya know I have you
haven't said well in two days what have
you been doing I've been traveling out
on in on Saturday in Alfred New York
that Alfred universe doing gigs
I mean if Alfred University mm-hmm I
remember Robert Klein referenced that in
his Robert Klein at Yale special you
absolutely are right he went Alfred
University how did you know that I love
Robert Klein and Robert Klein at Yale is
one of my favorite things ever and he's
talking about how it's it was it this is
Hornell New York Alfred Brown dear there
yes I'm talking about how rural it was
and [ __ ] uh he just didn't understand
the life there it was really a great it
is all very right you can I'm not
kidding if you have a horse you can keep
a horse there I am NOT making this up
what did you do it offered University
just as Santa oh okay and then I did if
it could college two nights ago and then
I was supposed to fly from Rochester to
here and that flight was canceled so I
bird for six hours
how much do berth for six hours it was
like four hundred bucks
that's bad for fifty or something which
if you hired a private car or rented a
car would be relatively simple more like
talking to the driver the whole time
yeah name was John Costello he's a
really great guy
former football player big Bills fan he
to kids he was great so you you uh your
flight was canceled they would have been
a horrible flight anyway if it hadn't
been canceled the [ __ ] uh yeah the
turbo bomb said what did you better
watch is Oberon
will you drive when you drive with uber
do you know where you're going before
you pick up the person or is it one of
those things we're never used uber no I
know what I'm saying does the driver
know where he's going
me not until they get not until you get
in the car I don't think right so does
that mean a guy in Rochester was like oh
[ __ ]
no no I would cuz when I I could
something happened with uber where I
typed in that no cuz they know they see
I think they can see it right out not
right no because that I am actually was
wrong they can see how far it so they
have some guys do okay but I could not
type in Manhattan on uber so I typed an
if
and allowed me to go there and then I
just kept ready with it redoing the trip
I like 50 miles further go you can't do
it well I don't know what happened I
kept lying to change her and then so and
then then it would not let me go to
Manhattan and then he just said I'll
I'll Drive you don't worry okay oh yeah
I gave him a lot of money so wait a
minute gave him six grand hey man fine
fine means nothing to me I didn't
realize you couldn't book such I guess
you can't book an uber trip to Florida
then you can't do that you I think I
mean you I think you could right I did
call the guy to go lie I'm well I'm
going to it's gonna be six hours of us
together if you don't mind and he was
like let's do it so did you know it did
you know your name on there that he
realized I have a celebrity in the car
he at one point he he got in and he kept
looking at me and he's like are you on
TV and then he his wife called she goes
you're not gonna believe this I've got
Joel Osteen in the car ok well it's joel
edgerton so he did but he did say Joel
Osteen which is like a you did not you
know that's fine do you correct people I
get that a lot like if I if I go out
where people will say like what have you
been here before and I know they know me
from stand-up or if if they're black
they've seen like me and power like I
usually know where they know me from but
I never say I'm a performer I'll just go
there like what do I know you from like
I come here a lot and like oh okay they
don't want to follow it up even though
they kind of know you know I never want
to assume somebody knows what I'm
performing almost annihilated my
standard would be so great look man I'm
Jim Martin no no no we were cuz no I
always say I as a I always say I'm
Matthew Lillard and I was in and I
started listening his credits off and a
lot of people be like oh total Matthew
Lillard dairy free music Scooby Doo
don't know who's a big star to my
favorite films to put yeah there we go
see you recognizes Matthew Lillard if
you wanted to it is yeah so all your
tall we we yes I think we're from the
city say someone we look like me Matthew
Lillard I look like he
he and Rainn Wilson kind of look like
each other maybe a little Rainn Wilson
Joel Osteen was up here once and he said
hi to me like he was really like it's so
great to meet you and like double handed
handshake and I was like yeah me you too
and I was just like oh that was really
nice I guess he's just that nice of a
charismatic though and you met him boo
yeah he scares me yeah but he was like
locked in and he was like but he seemed
like really happy to meet me and the
next day the talent Wrangler that was
walking him around he was like hey Sam
did you meet Joel Osteen yesterday and I
was like yeah and I go oh I wonder her I
mean I don't think he would listen to
this radio show but I wonder if he knew
me from something or something and and
the talent Wrangler goes oh he thought
you were Malcolm Gladwell just saw the
hair and we had must remark that's it
clearly looks like without glasses joel
osteen claims that he can bench like 350
really he or three he can bench her
that's can you look that up yeah you do
look like Malcolm Gladwell I do have a
Malcolm I'm you look better though why
do people like Malcolm Gladwell's cause
of that outliers book his books are
great I watched are good but then he had
um then he had some trouble on cast with
forgery yeah he had no yeah well after
we find a or or if some sort of he had
seen something like that plagiarism I
watched it this is great
I love this show called Wikipedia figure
yeah yeah yeah make wild accusations
they look good they're like I was in the
airport all you see is like a [ __ ]
rack with all of eight of his books on
there and you're looking out like [ __ ]
that looks good but I just know me I'll
start it and get bored as soon as the
plane lands he wrote a book about David
now David versus Goliath and then like I
watched him do a TED talk where he was
retelling the story about why David
wasn't this underdog and he was actually
very skilled and if Goliath had taken
time to know what David's skill set was
he would have known that David would
clearly win and this was going something
to Malcolm Gladwell right now I can't
tell the difference I remember well by
the whole thing yeah I was like this is
great I look at David versus Goliath
completely differently oh that's okay
and it gives a [ __ ] how do you know
anyway what does it say with studio
controversy
shut up
you're exactly I would have [ __ ]
kicked you in the chest nice game
thought it was he's an educated man oh
there's the plate there that voyeurism
problem thing is it it was in the
Crimson someone maybe some maybe
someones stealing from him right yeah
let's get back to the Joel Osteen
benchpress thing yeah how much did he
laugh is jaw is chisel do you know you
can you bench a lot obviously I would
normally not ask against that but you
are relatively Jackson I would ask you
if you were choosing not no no it's just
a powdered HGH oh it is no you have
cancer helped you when you said are you
yawning are you asking him if he's
drinking juice or see that's the come on
yeah no that would be a horrible mistake
testosterone shots guys take I don't
take them but it's obviously I don't air
but guys take them and they're supposed
to be good you helpful I consistently
make you I just don't want to be hairy
I took HD HD you kid they might help
with my erections though cuz that is so
short here's a shrimp yeah how did it
look at head taller now but I'm skinny
fat so you know but that's not now we're
gonna you says see this is not where
you're gonna go through the whole
interview no I just want to see him
actually benching three there we go
there it is
that's not him that's just Joel just
Billy Joel try to get to a 300 pound
bumper off him yeah I would recommend
people use HGH I worked well for me the
kid can make a pay for it later
well you but people that do it I feel to
grow their muzzles can grow as its
everything grows including cancer but
also but what is that the testosterone
doesn't necessarily do that to you if
you take it like Rogan takes it I think
my pal Matt Sarah takes it it's like
healthy like if you work out there but
everyone knows Joe Rogan totally out of
shape I was looking at Joe Rogan could
leg kick of like a pillar of a building
down he literally looks like a gorilla
like I was watching Joe walk and he's
just like a solid [ __ ] primary yeah
yeah ape
yeah well he must work out three hours
yeah it's constantly kicking he's got
that he does he just see yeah he just
kicks the heavy bag until he's [ __ ]
ripped it's um a if you had said that
guy from Newsradio is going to be as big
as he has become not just physically now
is it yeah as a people forget before UFC
but like in his greatest great podcast
Joe had [ __ ] a fear factor like he
was known a celebrity for news radio for
species
oh my god he's been he's also been a
[ __ ] he's you know again I met him in
first in like 94 93 why would he we
could kick your ass back Danny but I
cuando guy I would not wear shirts if I
was joe rogan if that's what I look like
without a shirt on I wouldn't you'd
never you never catch me in a shirt ever